[Música]
Olá minhas amigas meus amigos sejam
muito
bem-vindo para mais uma
live Boa noite
Cristina temos 12 perguntas para
responder tá bem menos que a semana Pass
né que a gente tinha uma
sobrecarga hoje tá mais
tranquilo me digam se o áudio está bom
Cristina por favor você que está ao vivo
acompanhando me diga se o áudio Tá bom
eu tô com microfone novo só que ele tá
um pouquinho longe da minha boca por
causa que o suporte eu comprei para
utilizá-lo não ficou bom na posição mais
próxima na na minha boca que bom então
vamos responder as
perguntas boa noite gostaria de saber Ah
deixa eu primeiro tentar dividir a tela
aqui
OK assim
Boa noite D
Alan gostaria de saber se Suplementos
sobrecarregam o rim eem fígado uma vez
que são manipulados em
farmácia não necessariamente a questão
de sobrecarregar o
rim não quer dizer que é porque é da
farmácia manipulação que vai
sobrecarregar o rim ok o que vai
determinar se vai sobrecarregar o rim ou
não é se você tá utilizando ele da forma
correta então se você ingerir alguns
suplementos de maneira inadequada doses
muito altas sim você pode sobrecarregar
rim e fígado especialmente se ele já
estiverem comprometidos né o Rim é
importantíssimo para filtrar o sangue
vocês sabem disso o fígado é o principal
órgão metabólico que
vai processar todas as substâncias do
organismo inclusive vai fazer o detox
Então os dois órgãos são órgãos de detox
só que o fígado ainda mais importante
que o rim para essa
finalidade e se você tomar uma dose
excessiva de qualquer suplemento seja se
você comprou na farmácia comum ou se
você
[Música]
comprou na manipulação ou se você
comprou na internet não faz diferença a
origem Onde você comprou é a quantidade
e a e também no tempo que você utilizou
esse
suplemento por exemplo a vitamina A
eh na forma de palmitato de retinol ela
não é tóxica em doses muito elevadas mas
se você utilizar uma vitamina A numa
forma sintética ele vai ter mais
possibilidade de
intoxicar vitamina E é mesma coisa o
alfa tocoferol ele tem mais potencial de
intoxicar do que a tocotrienois né
então tem estudos falando que tanto a
vitamina A quanto a vitamina E
sintéticas eles são problemáticos pode
até aumentar o risco de alguns cânceres
tem um estudo clássico aí da vitamina A
aumentando o risco de câncer de pulmão
por exemplo mas a vitamina A sintética
em doses inadequadas então o ferro e o
cálcio também se você consumir em
excesso vão dar problemas né o cálcio
pode calcificar o rim pode calcificar
tecidos
moles o o ferro pode gerar uma
hemocromatose pode te gerar uma
inflamação sistêmica né tanto ferro
quanto cáo também podem denificar fígado
e
rins alguns suplementos herbais alguns
fitoterápicos são particularmente
problemáticos é o caso por exemplo do
hipérico o hipérico ou Erva de São João
se você tomar ele acima da quantidade
recomendada você vai ter problema
então é sempre importante você saber o
que você tá fazendo preferência tá sendo
acompanhado orientado por profissional
de saúde médico nutricionista e na
ausência desses profissionais você
estudar bastante o assunto para não
fazer bobagem
Ok boa noite D Alan gostaria de saber
ess suplementos nos que eu já respondi
Ah é eu polei uma pergunta aqui tenho 70
anos fui orientado a devido a idade a
tomar vacina contra o
Oster essa é uma vacina segura vale a
pena
tomar
Olha eu tenho um pouco de reserva com
essa vacina eu acho que você tiver tido
muitas Cris de herps dó né que é causado
pelo vírus da varicela que é da família
do herps
eu acho que convém sim você tomar mas se
você tá tomando só por causa da idade eu
não
tomaria o que eu faria nesse caso é
tomar lisina se você
tem uma chance par particularmente alta
de ter herps ou se você nunca teve herps
Hoster seria melhor até não tomar nada
tá Eu particularmente S tomaria essa
vacina em caso assim de uma pessoa que
teve muitas crises de herpis Oster tá eu
tenho P atrás que essa vacina Eu acho
que o risco benefício dela não
compensa
Ok próxima pergunta
eh se possível pode surgerir um
tratamento natural para baixar o ácido
úrico sim tem um tratamento natural para
baixar o ácido úrico uma uma planta
chamado
permin
nária béria uma
planta que baixa o ácido úrico OK tá no
chat
aí tem outra coisa que queria falar
sobre isso é tem que ter uma dieta
equilibrada
cortando os alimentos processados
industrializados especialmente os
alimentos ricos em charope de milho de
alta frutose a frutose aumenta muito o
ácido úrico e tem aquela orientação
clássica de evitar alimentos ricos em
purinas né que é o caso da carne
vermelha no frango nos
Mariscos alguns tipos de peixes Tá mas
isso é menos importante do que você
cortar o xarope de Mira em alta frutose
beber bastante água muito importante
tambémm chá de gengibre pode
ajudar chá de camomila também pode
ajudar suco de limão tem citrato que
pode ajudar a dissolver cálculos de
cristais de ácido
úrico Mas isso é só se o cálculo for de
ácido úrico puro a CCA pode ajudar pelas
propriedades antiinflamatórias
antioxidantes mas o principal aí é a
terminara eléc que eu coloquei aí na
tela para vocês e tá no chat
também bem vamos paraa próxima
pergunta
H na Live passada você sugeriu que
poderia responder essa pergunta
posteriormente por isso tô repetindo a
empresa nutrimentos foi vendida paraa
empresa nlab daí o suplemento intimate
performance mudou o nome para Active
performance além de mudar o nome do
suplemento eles fizeram algumas mudanças
nesse suplemento segundo eles a mudança
foi para
melhor Ok vamos olhar esse suplemento
aqui a parte que explica mudança é nlab
science.com.br active performance tal
tal
tal tá Mas qual que é a pergunta que
você quer fazer
Você não deixou a pergunta aqui Ah tá
você também acha que a mudança foi para
melhor ou
pior
é vamos entrar nessa página e ver né
ué Ah tá não coloquei ao final da do
link Ah nutrimentos agora
nlab aumentar lá lenina de 800 para
MG aumentar o ASO aspártico de 600 para
8 80 taurina trocar pel
lanina aí eles estão dizendo que por
causa dessas mudanças vai ter ereções
mais firmes e consistentes melhor
equilíbrio hormonal controle de estresse
foco e maior sinergia É parece que as
mudanças são positivas né eu diria que
as mudanças eu teria mantido a taurina e
acrescentada a l teanina mas não achei
as mudanças ruins não pelo contrário
acho que vale a pena experimentar esse
produto Ok próxima pergunta para C de
Renault e varizes nos pés quercetina e
com enzima q10 seri indicado ou teria
algo a mais que eu recomendaria
quercetina é um antiinflamatório natural
certo ele vai ser específico para
Renault não não vai ser específico para
Renault ele vai ser mais específico para
bloquear Amina ele é um antistamínico
natural mas certamente esses dois ativos
ajudariam porque que cetina é um
antiinflamatório natural e a coema q10
ajudaria na saúde dos vasos Ok só que eu
comentei isso na Live anterior eu
recomendaria
utilizar natoquinase
picnogenol L arginina L citrulina
norvaline são todos os agentes que
aumentam o óxido nítrico vitamina C
também então que cetina vitamina C L
citrulina L arginina norvaline
natoquinase picnogenol seria uma ótima
combinação com enzima que1 não é tão
vaso dilatadora mas Poderia
ajudar
acetina ajudaria mais no sentido ser um
flavonoide que anda muito bem com a
vitamina C
o Jin cobiloba também Seria uma boa
opção porque ele também é vaso dilatador
a vimpocetina também é vaso dilatadora
Poderia ajudar seria outra opção e
exercícios físicos regulares Seria muito
bom também hidratação adequada Ok
ã Quais são os melhores exames para
diagnosticar
lipedema essa pergunta Seria melhor se
ela fosse direcionada a d Ana Paula né
Mas vamos lá que que é lipedema é uma
inflamação e acúmulo anormal de
gordura nos membros especialmente nas
pernas
Ok como é que você faz o diagnóstica
basicamente exame físico história
Clínica né um tipo de inchaço que
acontece nos membros nas pernas que é um
inchaço está no tecido
gorduroso Quais são as características
principais ou típicas né é uma gordura
macia e
dolorosa e não tem enchaço no pé OK
então você vai ter um inchaço nas pernas
no tecido gorduroso doloroso e não tem
inchaço no pé e o ultrassom pode ser
utilizado para confirmar a presença de
gordura subcutânea anormal e distinguir
o lipedema de outras condições como o
linfedema que é um edema linfático Ok a
ressonância pode ser utilizada em alguns
casos também para avaliar essa
distribuição de gordura de uma maneira
mais
adequada e para prevenir a piora disso
daí é cortar alimento processado
industrializado refinado açúcar
farinhas baixar o
peso exercícios regulares que vão ajudar
muito na bomba muscular das pernas
especialmente exercício nas pernas né
que é o lugar onde mais tem lipedema
fazer as massagens linfáticas famosas a
terapia compressiva mes de compressão e
outras técnicas de compressão pode
ajudar reduzir dor inchaço
né manter a Pele Saudável seja com ácido
hialurônico seja usando
colágeno usando silício
orgânico msm também vai ajudar é
basicamente isso daí tá bom
sobre o manejo de ep plasia prostática
benigna o senhor me falou de alguns
fitoterápicos dentro deles tem um
extrato de p de trigo sim tá no produto
da Life
extension enconte uma faa life como você
colocou aqui Triple strength Prost poen
mas tem também no prostate deles lá não
tem só nesse produto não tá a
pessoa logo pensa que resolve o problema
com uma garrafa
garrafa não é um frasco é uma garrafa
mas acho que você quis dizer frasco né
Qual é o manejo correto da D deve ser
Qual é o manejo correto para desinchar
próstata
uso por algum tempo não você tem que
usar eles continuamente tá ou no mínimo
mínimo se meses tá checo nra sim depois
6 meses de uso faz ultom se resolver o
problema dependo não vai resolver o
problema vai controlar o problema você
vai ter que tomar Provavelmente o resto
da vida tá ou a fazer cirurgia da
próstata para não ter que tomar o resto
da vida e
Dependendo para o tratamento como eu
falei na melhor das hipóteses você vai
tomar se meses sim se meses não mas você
não vai parar de tomar no sentido de
tomar só uma época e nunca mais tomar
OK já expliquei
isso tenho medo de diminuir muito o
tamanho da próstata e torná-la
disfuncional não vai acontecer isso
esquece que não vai acontecer tá é o
medo bobo seu lógico bobo não no sentido
de tá te xingando tá é no sentido de ser
o medo não calcado na realidade tá como
devo proceder já expliquei se meses sim
seis meses não no no mínimo ou tomar
direto agora temos também de opção mais
barato extrato de pólen de senteio Esse
graminex é uma fórmula concentrada
patenteada com valor bastante expressivo
ok mas também não obrigado tomar o exato
pem não tá tem outros ativos tem o pig
africano Tiga de oica o sol pometo o
extrato do abacateiro que tem lá
otipo tem também na abóbora né abóbora
que é o Bet
citerol esse problema da Próstata é um
problema intestinal Não não é um
problema intestinal que fica absorvendo
reabsorvendo hormônios que deveriam ser
eliminados não isso é uma questão do
estradiol que é mais problemático em
mulheres tá mulheres T muito constipação
mas tem muito menos constipação do que
mulher e aí o estrogênio vai sendo
reabsorvido vai fazendo um ciclo vicioso
de reabsorção de estrogênio mas em homem
geralmente não é muito significativo tá
e se tiver também significativo no homem
pode usar eh o dinin de endol metano
endol escabin e pode usar também o deglu
carato né para evitar essa reabsorção de
estrogênio
eh e na passagem pelo intestino acaba
sendo reabsorb tar expliquei isso são os
hormônios velhos qual a teoria o senhor
acredita não ah
existe duas teorias principais e uma
terceira teoria também as duas
principais é excesso de DHT porque a
testosterona vai caindo 1% ao ano nos
homens a partir dos 40 anos de idade E
aí com a queda da testosterona o corpo
tenta compensar com aumento do DHT essa
é uma teoria por isso que se usa
basicamente bloqueador de 5 Alfa redut
que faz a conversão de testosterona em
DHT essa primeira teoria que é mais
aceita a segunda teoria é excesso de
estradiol nos hom especialmente Os
homens vão engordando vão envelhecendo e
o tecido gorduroso tem muito a
enzima aromatase que converte
testosterona em estradiol esse excesso
stradi também na prosta ajuda a
proliferar tecido prostático e a
terceira teoria é a teoria da inflamação
que a pessoa vai inflamando com o tempo
E especialmente pelo efeito aí dos
derivados do hormônio do crescimento no
caso seria o insulin like grow Factor né
o gf1 excesso gf1 que aumenta com a
inflamação também poderia ser
proliferativo paraa próstata Então essas
são as três teorias
principais os males para os minerais em
relação ao grão de aveia são os mesmos
por farelo
eu não entendi bem essa pergunta minha
sobrinha toma minerais básico mas comi
muito farelo de aveia não sei se eu
entendi essa pergunta aqui você acha que
a veia atrapalha a absorção de minerais
é
isso bem é bom você comer e a ver o
mínimo possível de processamento tá
farelo o grão é melhor porque vai ter
mais nutrientes e mais fibras
ok basicamente tanto grão de aveia
quanto farelo de aveia são ricos em
fibras vitaminas minerais como ferro
zinco Magnésio e fósforo isso vai ajudar
na sua saúde digestória vai ajudar a
controlar as gorduras do sangue
OK agora eu não tô lembrado de ter liido
que a Veia vai atrapalhar a absorção de
minerais e Mas mesmo que atrapalha é
muito simples de resolver isso né você
toma um mineral um horário diferente de
comer aveia n se você der uma intervalo
aí de uma hora entre um e outro não vai
ter essa interferência
Ok eu não sei se eu entendi a pergunta
mas se essa pergunta foi no sentido de
que consumir aveia vai
atrapalhar absorção de minerais consum
Mineral em outro horário mas como eu
falei a própria veia tem minerais
tem ferro
magnésio
certo zinco
fósforo se você tiver ao vivo talvez a
gente possa esclarecer um pouco mais
isso daí não sei se eu entendi a
pergunta
né Doutor uma proporção de PSA livre
Total inferior a 18 é você divide o
livre pelo total aí dá 0,18 que dá 18%
mas com PSA Total inferior a dois não
você só usa essa relação quando o PSA tá
acima de quatro abaixo de quatro não se
usa a relação tá deve ser motivo de
preocupação não ou essa relação só vale
para PS superior a quro Acabei de
responder Doutor Qual que é a dose
magnésio citrato que pode ser utilizada
diariamente para evitar a formação de
cálculos renais quando existe ingestão
de 1 g de vitamina C diária Qual é a
dose de magnes citrato pode ser
utilizada diariamente para evitar rmação
de cálculos não a vitamina C diária de 1
g dificilmente vai dar cálculo Só se
você tiver
muita predisposição a formação de pedra
né o Oxalato ele é formado pelo
processamento no organismo da vitamina C
se você tiver já hiperoxalúria
genética a vitamina C pode ser o último
empurrão que precisava para formar pedra
mas 1 g de vitamina C eu nunca vi
sinceramente pessoas bem hidratadas que
bebem água adequada eu nunca vi 1 Gama
de vitamina C da pedra nos índices tá eu
acho muito difícil você pode est
ingerindo aí por volta
de 200 a a 400 mg de magnésio rrato por
dia tá Dr Alan mostrei os dados abaixo
na última Live você havia endossado os
dados abaixo e lembro-me que você
comentou que embora esses dados sejam
verdadeiros a absorção é ainda menor não
é que ainda menor é porque não é porque
por exemplo o treonato tem mais
magnésio por peso de 500 mg do que o
glicinato Isso significa que tem mais
absorção foi isso que eu falei não sei
se você entendeu tá o glicinato ele é
mais
absorvido magnésio binato é mais
absorvido do que o treonato no intestino
isso não quer dizer tá que sejam piores
é só que a absorção é um pouco melhor
tá Sabe dizer qual que é o percentual de
absorção dos cinco primeiros itens
abaixo então a questão aqui é que
dependendo da fonte que você vai se Vai
checar
né Isso muda tá eu já vi algumas Fontes
falando em 20% de 20 a 30% outras fontes
falando entre 40
50% então isso não é uma pergunta
exatamente simples de responder
OK mas assim olhando todas as fontes eu
acho que a que a mais eu considero
confiável é que o magnésio de malato vai
absorver de 30 a
35% o treonato vai absorver
aproximadamente 40% e o glicinato
aproximadamente
45% o citrato vai ser por volta de 30% e
o taurato por volta de 35% Ok mas vai
variar muito de acordo com vários
fatores estado nutricional saúde
intestinal interação com outros
nutrientes que você vai tomar junto o
horário que você vai ingerir condições
do trato digestório ok O óxido de
magnésio ele tem uma absorção muito
baixa então de quatro a cco por C
Ok tenho visto algo sobre alguns médicos
usando in mectina e fermento da azol
para tratar câncer Inclusive eu estou
com quatro ou cinco pacientes usando
essa combinação tá bem complicado
arriscado entre aspas porque esse fento
da azol infelizmente só se acha ele na
forma veterinária no Brasil aí você tá
meio que dando cara a tapa
né parece ser algo novo o Senor ouviu
algo sobre isso vi eu tô acompanhando o
material do William Max e também tô
acompanhando os grupos no WhatsApp
discutindo sobre isso tá tem opinião não
tem opinião ainda totalmente
formada porque eu estou analisando ão
Meus Primeiros pacientes usando isso eu
vou precisar de alguns meses para poder
entender se isso de fato é real ou não
tá me pareceu que o inmax é muito
confiável que é um médico canadense que
tá divulgando isso muito na internet tá
tem um substack lá se vocês quiserem
acompanhar ele no
subsc vocês vão poder ver o material
dele Lógico que ele tem uma área fechada
lá que ele cobra né
mensalidade eu tô avaliando ainda se
vale a pena eu pagar para ter acesso à
área de membros
dele
bem respondemos às dúvidas do documento
ah Maria Helena tá falando aqui pergunta
do farelo de aveia vou localizar o seu
vídeo depois pergunto novamente é por
favor pode ser um vídeo que eu fiz há
bastante tempo e não tô lembrado
disso uma pessoa pode fazer dieta
cetogênica para
sempre Poder pode mas eu duvido que vai
fazer a não ser que seja
Alzheimer Não não é verdade ele o chega
de pergunta tá pessoal vamos falar dos
artigos senão a gente vai ficar o dia
inteiro aqui respondendo pergunta e
lembra do que aconteceu na outra Live né
foram 40 e Tantas perguntas e a gente
não conseguiu nem falar aqui dos artigos
né bem vamos
lá primeiro artigo que queria discutir
com vocês é um tema que impacta a vida
de milhões de pessoas tá deixa eu mudar
aqui a visualização
que é a síndrome do intestino irritável
Eu acho esse assunto fascinante é um dos
assuntos que eu mais gosto e muita gente
tem isso né eu mesmo sou um portador
desse problema aí e para mim foi um
grande desafio controlar isso na minha
vida então se você que tá assistindo
enfrentou dores abdominais inchaço
gases e
que poucos remédios são de fato efetivos
especialmente os remédios que os médicos
convencionais escreve que são
sintomáticos então prestem atenção Nesse
artigo recentemente teve uma revisão
sistemática abrangente que analisou
diversas intervenções para melhorar os
sintomas do intestino irritável
e os probióticos e uma dieta baixa em
fod
Maps foram as estrelas dessa
avaliação foram os itens que tiveram
maiores evidências de
eficácia então o estudo focou em
identificar quais eram as intervenções
que teriam as melhores evidências para
aliviar a se intestino irritável Então
os principais aspectos avaliados foram
sintomas a gravidade da condição e dores
abdominais então sintomas Gerais
gravidade e dores abdominais e além
disso a consistência das fezes e a
qualidade de vida também foram
considerados então para chegar a essas
conclusões
aproximadamente 35.000 participantes com
a síndrome foram incluídos na pesquisa
Então essa amostra bastante
significativa nos dá uma base confiável
para entender quais seriam os
tratamentos que realmente fazem
diferença dentro dessas avaliações Ok
pode ser que eles não colocaram muita
coisa aí da Medicina integrativa ou
funcional nessa avaliação então tendo
que esse estudo pode ter essa limitação
que eles possam ter utilizado remédios
que eu particularmente eu utilizo no meu
dia a dia tá mas como é que foi então
conduzido Esse estudo é uma revisão
abrangente uma revisão de revisões né
uma metanálise na verdade foi um estudo
Umbrella pegou várias metanálises e
juntaram então isso torna um estudo
muito poderoso né em termos
estatísticos E essas meta análises que
foram avaliadas eram de ensaios clínicos
randomizados então foram várias
intervenções uso de probióticos
prebióticos dieta baixa em fodmap
Lembrando que fodmap são substâncias são
açúcares que tem na alimentação que
fermentam né então o f de fodmap é
fermentable né o o É é um tipo
de Açúcar o d outro tipo de Açúcar tá E
tem também aí o p é o poli ois tá que é
um tipo de também de álcool e para vocês
terem uma ideia esses eritritol
Manitol esses adoçantes famosos aí que
tem ol no final são polióis Ok então são
todos alimentos que fermentam no
intestino por isso que a dieta baixa em
forma de Map é muito boa para quem tem
intestino
irritado então eles avaliaram a dieta
baixa de Map probiótico prebiótico fibra
Glutamina óleo de hortelã pimenta né
Aloe Vera vitamina D cúrcuma e até uma
fórmula da medicina chinesa que é o
tonch Fang
tch Fang não sei pronunciar em
chinês então eles compararam essas
intervenções com Placebo que a pílula de
farinha Então quais foram os resultados
que os probióticos e a deet baixa em
fmap que foram que tiveram mais mais
efeitos positivos
nos principais desfechos da cind do
intestino irritável só que eu tenho
vários pacientes que não se dão bem com
probiótico dependendo do probiótico até
piora né o intestino irritável Então
isso é bem complexo mesmo então os
probióticos tiveram um efeito pequeno a
moderado nessas metanálises aí com uma
certeza de evidência de baixa moderada
baseado de 6 a 46 estudos
já dieta baixa em fmap também Apresentou
um efeito pequeno a moderado com uma
certeza de evidência moderada apoiada
por 8 a 20 estudos além disso a dieta
baixa em F map ela foi a única
intervenção que melhorou a consistência
das fezes e a qualidade de vida dos
pacientes embora com efeito pequeno e
uma certeza de evidência baixa baseada
em 11 estudos então isso interessante
pra gente analisar Óbvio que eu acho que
eles não usaram várias das Ferramentas
que eu uso nos meus tratamentos nessas
metanálises então por isso que tem que
levar isso em consideração Ok bem o
próximo
estudo é sobre dietas
lowcarb Esse estudo particularmente ele
avaliou dietas larb consumo de ovos e o
que que isso tinha a ver com a saúde
cardiometabólica Então esse estudo
inovador investigou os efeitos de uma
dieta cetogênica asiática que inclui o
consumo di áo de ovos em pessoas com
síndrome metabólica pessoas que tinham
então aumento de Açúcar aumento da
circunferência abdominal aumento da
pressão
arterial alteração de LDL colesterol e
alteração
de triglicérides Então os resultados
mostraram melhorias na regulação da
glicose no curto prazo mas essas
melhorias não se mantiveram após o
período de
acompanhamento ou seja teve uma melhora
Inicial que depois não se Manteve Então
vamos entender melhor o que que eles
quiseram dizer com
isso então o foco principal do estudo
foi analisar como uma dieta cetogênica
asiática com ou sem ovos afetaria os
fatores de risco
cardiometabólicos Então os pesquisadores
avaliaram colesterol HDL colesterol
Total LDL triglicerides ou triglicérides
o peso o índice de massa corporal a
circunferência da cintura pressão
arterial controle glicêmico e marcadora
de inflamação então participaram do
estudo 76 pessoas idade média de 41 anos
predominantemente mulheres todas com
Cine metabólica então foram divididos em
três grupos um seguindo uma dieta
cetogênica com gema de ovo outro com
clara de ovo você tirou a gema só deixou
a clara e um grupo controle uma dieta
balanceada em baixo teor calórico então
durante 52 semanas participantes do
grupo cetogênico reduziram a ingestão de
carboidratos para menos de 50 G por dia
sem restrições de gorduras e proteínas
já o grupo controle reduziu a ingesta
calórica em 20% mantendo a distribuição
específica de macronutrientes que não
era da dieta
cetogênica no entanto muitos
participantes abandonaram o estudo ao
longo do tempo que impactou a Adesão à
dieta cetogênica Então veja bem a
pergunta do Eliseu aí né é difícil a
pessoa fazer se meses cetogênica Imagina
fazer o resto da vida então os
resultados most que nas primeiras 12
semanas a dieta cetogênica com gema de
ovo melhorou de maneira significativa a
insulina de jejum a resistência insulina
e os níveis de glicose durante o teste
de tolerancia glicose Então já a dieta
com clara de ovo reduzi os níveis de
glicose e marcadoras de
inflamação
contudo essas melhorias não se
mantiveram ao longo do não se mantiveram
ao longo do tempo no longo prazo e
muitos participantes aumentaram a gestão
de carboidratos ao longo do estudo que
eu tô te falando o problema aqui foi que
eles não conseguiram manter a dieta
cetogênica por muito tempo além disso a
dieta cetogênica resultou em um aumento
nos níveis de colesterol total em
LDL especialmente nas primeiras 35
semanas isso para mim não é um problema
se você considerar que esse LDL que tá
subindo não é o LDL que vai oxidar né
Então vai depender
do que tipo de alid é de partícula
pequena ou densa ou não que vai
aumentar mas segundo os autores do
estudo isso é preocupante porque todo
mundo já sabe disso né que a medicina
Ortodoxa considera que níveis elevados
de LDL estão Associados a maior risco de
doenças
cardiovasculares mesmo com orientações
para aumentar a ingestão de vegetais e
fibras que nós sabemos que fibras também
diminui esse colesterol LDL e também
minimizar o consumo de gorduras
saturadas com aumento de colesterol
ainda foi observado que para mim não é
particularmente
preocupante se você considerar que seja
um colesterol de boa
qualidade Outro ponto importante é o
consumo de ovos embora os ovos sejam
ricos em nutrientes como proteínas B12
cina e selênio seu alto teor de
colesterol pode impar de forma negativa
os níveis de Arida em algumas pessoas
Sim mas de novo que tipo de Arida que tá
subindo no entanto estudos indicam que
consumir Dois a três ovos por dia não
afeta de forma significativa LDL ou
controle glicêmico quando inseridos numa
dieta balanceada Eu como três ovos todos
os dias em resumo então a qualidade
geral da dieta é o mais importante é é o
crucial substituir ovos por alimentos
Vegeta como noses leguminosas e grãos
integrais pode trazer benefícios
adicionais paraa saúde cardiovascular e
metabólica eu não concordo com isso
Inclusive eu quero falar sobre o tma que
vai ser o próximo estudo que eu vou
discutir
aqui estudos mostram que essas
substituições estão associadas a menores
riscos de doenças cardiovasculares
diabetes tipo do e mortalidade geral
recentemente eu vi um estudo dizendo que
ovos e aumentar o risco de
diabetes eu acho isso bem complicado
essa esse tipo de conclusão então o que
que você deve levar para casa desse
estudo né se você quer fazer uma dieta
cetogênica oloc carb foque na qualidade
dos alimentos e evite né até a gente ter
certeza absoluta comer mais do que cinco
ovos por dia
OK Ou se você quiser também você pode
tirarla as gemas e cons consumir as
claras apesar que eu não gosto muito
dessa
estratégia tá o último artigo desta
noite eu vou deixar outros pra semana
que vem é sobre um mistério uma questão
que vem assombrando né vários médicos ao
longo dos anos e também é um grande tema
de debate na comunidade de nutrição e
médica que a relação entre o TM ao Eu
tenho um vídeo sobre isso no canal de
alguns anos atrás o risco cardiovascular
e o consumo de ovos a
trimetilamina ela é
metabolizada no organismo e vira o tmao
que alguns anos atrás sa um estudo falou
que se aumentava o risco cardiovascular
ok então nós vamos avaliar se isso é
verdade ou não E se os ovos eles são
realmente os vilões ou são apenas mal
interpretados então o tmao é o
trimetilamina n óxido o composto ele tem
sido identificado como biomarcador de
risco para doenças cardiovasculares
alguns estudos TM mostrado uma
correlação entre níveis elevados de tmao
e um aumento no risco de eventos
cardiovasculares então por exemplo uma
coorte com 4000 pessoas submetidas à
angiografia coronariana encontrou uma
correlação posit só que fraca positiva
só que fraca entre os níveis de tmao e
risco cardiovascular com um HR né que é
o Razer Rachel
[Música]
tá o Hazard ra né que é um tipo de risco
relativo que então foi aumentado foi um
risco relativo de
13% que daria aumento de risco aí de 30%
a mais ok
mais impressionante ainda só que 30% de
aumento de risco relativo né Se você ver
o risco absoluto vai ser um número muito
menor o risco de morte por doença
cardiovascular
eh em alguns estudos foi de três vezes
maior em pessoas que tinham níveis
elevados de
tmao Na minha opinião essa questão do
trimetil lamina tá muito mais
relacionado a microbioma intestinal do
que consumo de ovos ou consumo de Colina
ou consumo de carnetina que são as
fontes tma
Ok bem vamos falar como é que o tma é
formado no corpo ele surge quando a
Colina ou a carnetina estão presentes na
nossa dieta né especialmente em ovos e
carnes eles são metabolizados por
microorganismos intestinais formando a
trimetilamina Então essa trimetilamina
ela pode ser oxidada por enzimas do
fígado formando
tmao então a composição da nossa
microbiota ela tem um papel muito
importante na formação de
tmao bem E os ovos em relação a
tmao os ovos são uma fonte muito
importante Colina na forma de fosfate de
Colina que é muito bom pro cérebro né
pro tecido neuronal a membrana
celular porém vários estudos Descobriram
que consumir até três ovos por dia
equivaleria a cerca de 400 mg de Colina
poderia elevar os níveis de Colina
plasmática mas não aumenta os níveis de
tmao Foi o que eu falei eu consumo três
ovos por dia então supostamente por
esses estudos mais recentes isso não
seria suficiente para aumentar os níveis
de tmao que seria esse elemento
problemático para doença
cardiovascular outras formas de Polina
como bitartarato de
Colina aparentemente aumentam de forma
significativa os níveis de
tmao então ele tá dizendo aqui que 600
MG de bitartarato de Colina podem
triplicar os níveis de tmao além disso
diferença na microbiota intestinal entre
indivíduos pode explicar essa
variabilidade na produção de tmal então
o que que significa pro consumo de ovos
isso vai ou não vai aumentar o risco
cardiovascular Então surpreendentemente
apesar do potencial dos ovos de aumentar
o tmao devido ao conteúdo de Colina
estudos mostram que o consumo de ovos
não está associado a aumento das doenças
cardiovasculares então isso sugere
que a relação entre ovos tmao e risco
cardiovascular não é tão direta quanto
parecia antes então parece que o papel
dos microorganismos intestinais é muito
mais importante na conversão das
trimetilaminuria com doenças
cardiovasculares os ovos não devem ser
culpados por aumentar os níveis de tmao
ou risco cardiovascular Ok mas consumam
até no máximo cinco ovos por dia OK a
ção da microbiota intestinal a
composição da microbiota intestinal e
fatores individuais pare muito mais
importantes ou críticos nesse processo E
além disso outros fatores de estilo de
vida como dieta balanceada prática
regular de exercícios podem
mitigar quaisquer riscos potenciais
associados ao tma beleza Ficou claro
pessoal
quantas pessoas estão acompanhando a
Live porque a última mensagem chegou
aqui foi às
7:44 da noite pela
Denise vocês estão acompanhando pessoal
ou eu tô falando sozinho aqui eh que eu
não consigo ver quantas pessoas estão
online A não ser que vocês mandam
mensagem
mensagem do Eliseu aqui eu só vou
responder essa última pergunta pessoal
José Eduardo Ramos está dizendo que está
aqui é é isso mesmo aliz quanto mais
você faz atividade física mais sentido
tem de ingerir proteína
Ok esse seria um limite para quem não é
fisiculturista
Obrigado pelo Olá
ruberg obrigado Antônio Renato Obrigado
Osmar Eu que
agradeço bem pessoal estamos agora com
50 minutos de Live eu tenho um
compromisso daqui a pouco eu acho que eu
vou encerrar por aqui
quem tem cum fungic Elise eu Tem que
evitar pelo menos un dois meses qualquer
coisa fermentada até resolver o problema
tá depois pode voltar a consumir os
fermentados não meor fermentado pode
consumir
tranquilo pessoal Muito obrigado pela
presença de vocês até a próxima semana
Ah deixa eu ver uma coisa
aqui estamos próximo aí do natal e do
ano novo né
Ah vai cair bem no dia 24 no dia 31 eu
vou fazer uma votação depois no grupo
para saber se vocês querem que eu faça
live dia 24:31 ou a gente pula pro dia 7
eu acho melhor a gente pular pro dia 7
né
porque já tem pouca gente ao vivo aqui
nessas Live
vai ter menos ainda de
2431 mas eu vou colocar em votação
abraço até a próxima